she's 74 disabled and with a catalogue
of illnesses but miriam has given up on
trying to see her gp
if you're ill
you need to see somebody within that day
not tomorrow next week
you know it's the whole of the national
health service it's all of us it's it's
gone
it was remote consultations that helped
gps see patients through the pandemic
but that system doesn't work for people
like her they're just so busy aren't
they they just can't come out you've got
too many patients the hospitals give up
on me so the gps must give up on me i
just you know just feel as if they're
waiting for me to die
with a brutal winter ahead a form of
help is on the way a support package
from government which they say will
alleviate pressures
one-third face-to-face
and sometimes more and the rest are
terrible but with it surgeries will now
be ranked in new league tables that name
and shame those failing to offer enough
patient access today's package is all
about support it's about having more
appointments and having more prompt
appointments and allowing patients to
have more choice in in the way that
they've seen
in liverpool the country's leading gps
kicked off their annual conference but
instead of feeling supported today
they feel targeted
the malicious criticism of the
profession
by certain sections of the media and by
some politicians
as a result of the shift towards remote
working
introduced to keep our patients and our
teams safe and keep the service
operating
has been the worst that i can remember
in over 30 years as a gp
even before the pandemic gps were
pleading for help with some of that now
on the way government expects more
face-to-face contact with patients in
return but this all falls on the
backdrop of a creaking health service
which faced its busiest september on
record
gps are and will always remain the first
line of care for anyone
but with a damaged system and a burnt
out workforce
they feel the money is simply not enough
obviously we are short staff like every
other gp surgery in the country and that
means that we have to work um
around the clock really sometimes we
work until midnight 250 million pounds
what is it going to solve first is it
going to solve the appointments problem
is it going to solve
the health nicolas problem
to many working in primary care this
will feel like yet another plaster stuck
on a deepening wound
and its patients will suffer as the
pressure mounts in demand rasheed sky
news liverpool